FIRST, DEMOCRATIC SMASHER SMEAR
CAMPAIGN, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
ONE YEAR AGO, DEMOCRATS AND THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SHOWED THE WORLD HOW LOW THEY
WOULD GO.
HOW DIRTY THEY WOULD PLAY IN
ORDER TO DERAIL THE
SUPREME COURT NOMINATION OF
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
OF COURSE DESPITE THEIR BEST
EFFORTS, BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS
CONFIRMED BUT NOW RADICAL
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA ARE PICKING UP WHERE
THEY LEFT OFF.
SPEAK OF THE SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH BACK IN THE SPOTLIGHT.
>> A BOOK ON KAVANAUGH BY TWO
"NEW YORK TIMES" JOURNALIST
MENTIONS A PREVIOUSLY UNREPORTED
CLAIM.
>> A NEW ALLEGATION OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AGAIN
KAVANAUGH.
>> SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS ON THE
BRINK OR INJUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
>> WERE PREVIOUS INVESTIGATIONS
MISHANDLED?
>> Laura: THIS NEW SMASH AND
SMEAR CAMPAIGN, YOU MIGHT'VE
HEARD ABOUT IT FROM THESE TWO
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT IS IN
ORDER TO SELL A BOOK ABOUT THE
KAVANAUGH FIGHT.
LEWD ACCUSATIONS, THEY THREW
THEM OUT WITH NO EVIDENCE OR
EVEN A VICTIM.
THEY WERE QUICKLY SMACKED DOWN
BY REAL JOURNALISTS.
THAT SHOULD HAVE ENDED THIS
ENTIRE SHAMEFUL SAGA.
BUT IT DIDN'T.
THE AUTHORS ARE DEFENDING THEIR
VILE ARTICLE SINCE IT HAS NOW
BECOME POLITICALLY USEFUL TO
DEMOCRATS.
BUT THERE BIG BOMBSHELL ISN'T
FLOATING.
YOU SEE, "THE TIMES" EDITORS
DIDN'T WANT TO INCLUDE THE
VICTIM'S NAMES SO THEY OMITTED A
KEY DETAIL THAT UNDERMINES THE
ENTIRE ALLEGATION.
THIS SUPPOSED VICTIM HAS NO
MEMORY OF THIS EVER HAPPENING.
IT DIDN'T GIVE AN INTERVIEW.
NOW THE REPORTERS' EXCUSES ARE
ROLLING IN.
>> WE HAD HER NAME, AND "THE
TIMES" DOESN'T USUALLY INCLUDE
THE NAME OF THE VICTIMS SOME OF
THIS CASE, THE EDITORS FELT LIKE
IT WAS MAY BE PROBABLY BETTER TO
REMOVE IT.
>> DID YOU READ IT BEFORE IT
WENT TO PRINT?
>> WE THOUGHT WE HAD.
>> Laura: THEY THOUGHT THEY
HAD.
A NEW STORY HERE ALSO.
WELL, THEY WERE WRONG.
BUT DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE
SLANDEROUS CHARGE, THE DAMAGE
DONE.
FEW PEOPLE ARE MAKING TOO MUCH
OF THIS.
>> IT'S TWO PARAGRAPHS IN ALMOST
300 PAGE BOOK.
WE DID NOT MAKE A LOT OF THIS.
THE WORLD IS MAKING A LOT OF
THIS.
WE JUST PUT OUT EVERY FACT THAT
WE COULD FIND THAT HADN'T BEEN
REPORTED PREVIOUSLY.
>> Laura: BUT "THE TIMES AND
COURT REPORTERS, IN AN EXCERPT
USE TO HYPE THEIR BOOK, OMITTED
THIS KEY FACT.
WHAT IS IT THAT
CHRISTINE BLASEY FORD'S FRIEND
NOW DOUBTS HER CLAIMS THAT HE
KAVANAUGH EVER SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED HER.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
KAISER ALSO TOLD THE AUTHOR SHE
FELT PRESSURED BY FORD'S FRIEND
INCLUDING A FORMER FBI AGENT TO
CHANGE HER STORY.
OTHERWISE, THEY PUBLICIZED HER
PAST PROBLEMS WITH DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THAT?
NOW, WE'VE SEEN THIS TYPE OF
SMASH AND SMEAR JOB BEFORE WHEN
THE DEEP STATE EMPLOYED
SIMILARLY SLEAZY TACTICS IN AN
UNCORROBORATED ALLEGATION
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ALL THE WHILE MEDIA LAPDOG
SUPPORTING IT ALL WITHOUT A HINT
OF SKEPTICISM.
AND WHEN ALL TURNED OUT TO BE
HOGWASH, TALK ABOUT THE DOSSIER
ET CETERA, THE LEFT JUST MOVED
ON.
NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
BUT EVEN AFTER ALL THE
BACKTRACKING AND THE
CORRECTIONS, DEMOCRATS ARE STILL
USING THIS FAKE NEWS FOR
POLITICAL GAIN.
>> THE CALL FOR KAVANAUGH TO GO
IS NOW GROWING.
SIX OF THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
SAY KAVANAUGH SHOULD BE REMOVED
FROM THE BENCH.
>> WHAT SHOULD BECOME CLEAR IS
THAT HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
THE HOUSE ABSOLUTELY HAS THE
ABILITY TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> I THINK HE HAS DISQUALIFIED
HIMSELF FOR SERVICE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
HE SHOULD STEP DOWN OR BE
IMPEACHED.
>> Laura: I THINK HE
DISQUALIFIED HIMSELF, 0% NOW?
PREDICTABLY SAYING AOC HAS
RETURNED HER OWN VERDICT.
ALSO CALLING FOR KAVANAUGH'S
IMPEACHMENT AND HER PROVOCATEUR
PROTEGE, CONGRESSMAN
AYANNA PRESSLEY FOLLOWED UP WITH
A RESOLUTION IN THE HOUSE TODAY,
WHICH OF COURSE KAMALA HARRIS
SEEMED TO TAKE IT AS HER CUE TOA
SEEMED TO TAKE IT AS HER CUE TOT
SEEMED TO TAKE IT AS HER CUE TO.
KAMALA HARRIS IS PURSUING
JERRY NADLER TO INVESTIGATE, AND
JERRY NADLER TO INVESTIGATE, ANY
JERRY NADLER TO INVESTIGATE, ANS
JERRY NADLER TO INVESTIGATE, AN,
IMPEACH KAVANAUGH.
IF THEY DON'T ACT,
SENATOR HARRIS WANTS TO TURN IT
INTO THE NEXT MUELLER PROBE.
>> THE PROCESS BY WHICH HE WAS
CONFIRMED HAS CREATED A CRISIS
OF CONFIDENCE.
IN THAT COURT.
IF THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
DOESN'T ACT, LET'S APPOINT AN
OUTSIDE COUNSEL.
SOMEBODY WHO     WHO IS NEUTRAL,
SOMEBODY WHO     WHO IS NEUTRALW
SOMEBODY WHO     WHO IS NEUTRALO
SOMEBODY WHO     WHO IS NEUTRALC
SOMEBODY WHO     WHO IS NEUTRALN
REVIEW THE EVIDENCE IN THIS
CASE, DETERMINE THE
CREDITABILITY OF THE WITNESS.
WE HAVE TO PURSUE JUSTICE.
>> Laura: HERE THAT THOUGHT?
THAT'S THE SOUND OF KAMALA
FALLING OFF HER HIGH HORSE.
PURSUING JUSTICE?
IT'S THE LAST THING THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN.
THAT'S NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE, THREE
DECADES AFTER ANY ALLEGED
WRONGDOING.
ESPECIALLY ONE WITH INVISIBLE
VICTIMS.
AND THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IT.
THAT IS WHAT IS SO SICK ABOUT
ALL OF THIS.
WHERE TRUMP IS ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL SOWING PEACE AND
PROSPERITY, DEMOCRATS ARE SOWING
CHAOS AND CALAMITY.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO KAVANAUGH
IS A CLASSIC LEFT IS SMEAR
OPERATION.
THROW OUT CHARGES ALL OVER THE
TOP, INJECT THEM INTO THE MEDIA
ECOSYSTEM, COMPLIANT JOURNALISTS
WHO EAGERLY SPREAD THE FAKE
NEWS.
THE CHARGES ARE SO OUTRAGEOUS
THAT THEY ARE BENEATH RESPONSE,
BUT THE PRESS, POSSESSED WITH
ANTI-TRUMP HATRED, ENDLESSLY
REGURGITATES THEM OVER AND OVER,
HOPING TO INFLICT NATIONAL
DAMAGE AND THEY ARE DOING ALL OF
THIS WHILE CONTROLLING ONLY ONE
HOUSE OF CONGRESS.
I AM HERE TONIGHT TO TELL YOU,
OR ASK YOU, IMAGINE WHAT THEY
WILL DO IF THEY WIN THE
WHITE HOUSE AGAIN.
GIVE THEM THE PRESIDENCY OR THE
SENATE AND THEY WILL USE THE
POWER OF GOVERNMENT TO DO TO US
WHAT THEY ARE DOING TO
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THEY WILL DEMONIZE OPPOSING
VOICES AND WORKING TO SILENCE
THEM OR INTIMIDATE THEM.
BUT I HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT
FAIR-MINDED AMERICANS, ANYONE
WHO HAS A SON OR A BROTHER GOING
OFF TO COLLEGE OR IN THE
WORKPLACE WILL SEE THIS NEW
KAVANAUGH SMEAR FOR WHAT IT IS.
A SAD, REVEALING, AND DESPERATE